je pense que il est important dans une
démocratie d'avoir une opposition une
opposition qui soit une opposition à la
fois claire mais qui peut être positif
mais nous attendent et d'énumérer des
oppositions gannett vaut aujourd'hui au
pouvons nous rejoindre il y en a
d'autres sur lequel vous avez voté on
laisse l'opposition
où seuls extrême parce qu on est passé
rapidement sur la présidentielle premier
tour de la présidentielle près 60% de
nos concitoyens vote pour des candidats
on peut qualifier entre guillemets de
protestataires et donc est ce qu'on
imagine l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale incarnez simplement par et les
filles où le rassemblement national je
dis non qui a la place pour une
opposition d'une droite républicaine
allié à lui d ea et aux centristes et
que c'est même très important qu'elle
soit là c'est indispensable pour la
démocratie et c'est une des tâches que
je me donne dans les semaines qui
viennent désir soit rejetée en réunion
pour soutenir des candidats